we are now ready to learn how dynamic
program in Calgary it's work for finding
optimal passes in the graphs let's start
from this graph and let's try to figure
out how to move in this graph to reach
the source and who is the maximum number
of Attraction at every step there are
only two decision to make either to move
vertically or move horizontally south or
east so to arrive to the final
destination
we can either arrive by moving south or
moving west and let's define a variable
which is south or east of I J as the
length of the longest path from the
initial node node 0 0 to note I J in the
grid and of course we can immediately
write a simple recursive problem program
for computing south or east for an M for
the source final destination graphics it
is simply minimum of south or east of n
minus 1 M class weight of the vertical
edge into the final node or south or
east of an M minus 1 plus weight of
horizontal edge into the final knot and
as soon as we realized it there is a
very simple recursive algorithm pew ting
the optimal path to note I J and the
algorithm is called south or east and
the only thing the Sagar it does it's
compute alternative between two
scenarios moving to note I J using
critical edge or moving to note I J
using horizontal edge do you think this
audit will solve our problem if you
watch me when I explain the change
problem you will figure out that this
algorithm while being correct will take
enormous time to finish
we will be making recursive calls many
many times for a fixed value of I and J
and therefore we need to come up with
something better and let's try to do
diner to apply dynamic programming idea
for travelling concerns grid
well the optimal path for to reach node
0 of course we will see only 0
attractions so the score in this node
will be 0 the score in this note will be
1 because there is only one way to reach
is not by moving vertically the optimal
score to reach this node will be 5 which
is 1 plus 4 because there is no other
alternative and as a result we can
compute all values which describes the
length of the longest paths for the
first row and the first column on this
graph now something interesting start
what is the best way to reach this node
integrals note 1 1 should we move to
this node using horizontal or vertical
as south or east well if we move
horizontally into this node then the
length of the path will be 1 plus 3 and
if we move vertically the length of the
path will be 3 plus 0 of course we
choose to move horizontally because 1
plus 3 is larger than 3 plus 0 and we
know afterwards that optimal path to
this node has lands 4 and for the future
we represent the edge horizontal edge
that we use to reach this node as the
ball touch and we will see later why it
is important how about this edge the
same argument and we decide to move to
this node by using vertical edge in this
case and will continue from surface
let's just try one more time what about
this node how should we arrive to this
node in this case we compare 4 plus 2
which is 5 plus 2 5 plus 2 is larger
than 4 plus 2 and therefore if we choose
to arrive to this node by moving along
vertical edge so for the recurrency for
compute
longest processes the following we
define s IJ as the length of the longest
paths from initial node to IJ and s IJ
is simply maximum of s I - my j plus the
weight of the vertical edge or s IJ
minus 1 plus the weight of the
horizontal edge and after we finish this
dynamic programming procedure we will
can feel the value of longest passes for
every node and we'll learn that the
optimal path to the final destination
has length 34 when we are doing this
please note that in some cases instead
of making decision south or east we will
make a decision south and east for
example in this particular node they are
comparing 22 plus 0 which is equal to 20
plus 2 which means that both horizontal
and vertical edge entering into this
vertex are involved and now I hope it
will become clear why we were retaining
information about both edges because 34
the number in the last node tells us the
length of the longest path but it
doesn't tell us how this longest path
those traders in the graph but with his
bolt edges they can figure out because
we know that we arrive to the last node
marked by 34 by moon in clone horizontal
voltage here it is we arrived in the
note marked labeled by 32 once again by
moving by horizontal edge and we arrived
to this node labeled by 30 by moving to
long vertical edge the continued
backtracking in this way and sooner or
later we will arrive in the initial node
and the blue path shown on the slide is
actually an optimal path from the
initial to final destination in this
graph
and we now move from describing how
dynamic programming work in a simple
Manhattan grid to describing how it
works in arbitrary alignment graphs
you